[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 11 septembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de cette édition les
élections sénatoriales approchent c'est
au programme le 24 septembre
les listes sont révélés progressivement
et les centristes de l'udf et du modem
font front commun pour le scrutin dans
le département ils viennent de lancer
leur campagne
la cgt appelle demain une journée
d'action nationale contre la réforme du
code du travail mobilisation qui se
préparent également dans les rangs
yvelinois nous recevons sur ce plateau
sonia porot secrétaire départemental de
la cgt 78 et puis interview
exceptionnelle dans ce journal z s'est
confié à tv 78
le père de titeuf était vendredi dernier
à la lanterne à rambouillet pour une
interview
dessiner c'était la rentrée de
l'enseignement supérieur ce matin
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines organisée à cette occasion une
matinée la gouache dating à la maison de
l'étudiant martha panne de guyancourt
objectif faciliter l'arrivée des
nouveaux étudiants étrangers
cela vient clôturer une semaine
d'intégration à l'ue vs qu propos
recueillis par mélanie poté c'est
vraiment une activité un peu comme le
speed dating ou du coup ils vont
rencontrer des gens enfin d'autres
étudiants français parlé autour des
langues et essayer éventuellement de
trouver ce qu'on appelle un buddy donc
c'est à dire un étudiant français qui va
l'accompagner
et les dépendants pendant le déroulement
de ces études mais corps commence
demain donc je veux contrat d entre eux
et parce que j'y suis un peu nerveuse
donc ces items pour quelqu'un qui arrive
c'est très compliqué beaucoup de choses
pour s'inscrire
beaucoup de choses pour avoir des
papiers des choses comme ça donc c'est
très important
chaque année 1800 à 2000 étudiants
étrangers font leur entrée à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
eux aussi se rassemble mais c'est en
politique contrairement aux législatives
lui dei et le modem présente une liste
commune pour les sénatoriales dans les
yvelines
le scrutin se tient le 24 septembre et
cette union centriste vient de lancer sa
campagne dans le département est les
détails avec nicolas landry une union
des centristes dans les yvelines le
modem éludé y ont formé une liste
commune pour les élections sénatoriales
une alliance différente des élections
législatives lui d y était allée au
républicain le modem à la république en
marche
moi j'aurais souhaité faire une liste
d'union je pensais que pour un scrutin
comme et sénatoriales voilà ça avait du
sens de se réunir nous avons essayé
depuis plusieurs mois de faire une liste
commune avec la république en marche
il s'est trouvé que pour plusieurs
raisons ça ne s'est pas fait à notre
grand regret nous avons aussi plusieurs
fois 2-2 d'avoir des contacts et de nous
mettre sur liste commune ça ne s'est pas
fait
intitulé nos territoires au coeur du
projet national cette liste présente des
élus ancrés localement sur l'ensemble du
département des yvelines
chacun avec sa spécialité on retrouve
notamment laurent mazaury et georges
bélie à f2 élus centristes de saint
quentin en yvelines
ce qui m'intéresse sur cette liste c'est
justement la possibilité de
pouvoir travailler et faire remonter des
idées qui viennent de terrain et donc
pouvoir les exposer au niveau du sénat
avec un projet focaliser sur la commune
le but est de réconcilier les zones
rurales avec les territoires urbains et
des propositions en termes de finances
publiques locales
si on partage une grande partie des
réformes du président macron je pense
que notamment sur sur le volet fiscal
il faudrait que ce soit modifié je
préférerais qu'on reparte sur un vrai
pacte fiscal et qu'on l'inscrivent dans
le marbre de la constitution de manière
à garantir
aux communes les moyens de leur
existence tout en leur laissant aussi un
levier de fiscalité locale objectif pour
l'union des centristes obtenir au moins
deux sièges au sénat
face à eux onze autres listes les
élections sénatoriales se tiendront le
dimanche 24 septembre
c'est un peu la mode du moment créer son
mouvement politique valérie pécresse
elle a lancé hier est libre depuis la
butte dors je mens à argenteuil dans le
val d'oise la présidente les
républicains de la région ile de france
entend proposer une troisième voie entre
la droite dure et les constructif elle
souhaite un courant enfermé sociale et
réformateurs plus de 2000 personnes
étaient présentes pour ce lancement pour
nous parmi lesquels à des élus les
républicains 75 ont d'ailleurs apporté
leur soutien à valérie pécresse dont les
yvelinois david douillet othman nas
roues et nicolas dainville c'est la
première grande mobilisation sociale
depuis l'élection d' emmanuel macron la
cgt appelle demain une journée d'action
nationale pour s'opposer à la réforme du
code du travail
les ordonnances qui vont réformer ce
code du travail ont été présentés pour
rappel le 31 août dernier par le premier
ministre edouard philippe
et des cortèges de toute la france vont
venir défilé dans les grandes villes
c'est le cas à paris ou des yvelinois
vont se rendre demain on en parle avec
notre invité sonia porot bonsoir bonsoir
est la secrétaire départementale de la
cgt
soixante dix huit premières questions
quels sont les objectifs de ce
rassemblement on l'a compris protester
contre la réforme du code du travail
mais qu'espérez-vous finalement de cette
journée d'action demain
d'abord
enclencher une vraie dynamique de
mobilisation à la fois sur les
ordonnances qui sont la prolongation de
la loi travail contre laquelle on a
beaucoup mobilisé l'an dernier et puis
également sur d'autres sujets qui vont
venir dans l'agenda la réforme des
retraites l'assurance chômage
et puis les salariés dans les
entreprises les retraités les chômeurs
les précaires ont énormément de
revendications aussi spécifique et c'est
aussi l'occasion de se faire entendre
sur ses revendications la dans leur
entreprise ou leur localité
plusieurs thématiques donc et ça remonte
bien avant l'élection d' emmanuel macron
vous l'avez dit c'est dans la continuité
finalement de la protestation contre la
loi travail est effectivement et tout le
travail qu'on a mené pendant la loi
travail pour expliquer l'inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes qui va se
généraliser avec les ordonnances porte
ses fruits et il ya vraiment une
mobilisation qui s'annonce d'ampleur on
a huit cars remplis qui vont partir de
2,5 ville des yvelines pour aller à la
manifestation parisienne
finalement pourquoi ce timing on l'a dit
les annonces ont été faites le 31 août
par edouard philippe
c'était important est de vite se
mobiliser de vite répondre à ces
ordonnances
ah oui le gouvernement a fait les choses
dans l'urgence non pas avec un une vraie
négociation tout le monde est autour de
la tam et des séries de petites réunions
avec chaque organisation séparément donc
on savait dès avant la rentrée quand
même la philosophie du texte et on
souhaitait donc mobiliser rapidement et
pour une une journée d'action si proche
de la rentrée s'annonce assez fort
est-ce que soyez pro vous regrettez
aussi le manque d'union tête des
syndicats autour de ce mouvement alors
on l'a dit appel principalement de la
cgt même s'il ya également avec la cgt
solidaires fsu et l'unef est ce que
c'est pour vous pensez que c'est une
faiblesse pour pour cette mobilisation
la cgt cherche toujours à créer l'unité
et on a eu encore au niveau national une
réunion avec l'ensemble des
organisations qui toutes se sont dit
déçus aux critiques par rapport aux
ordonnances à des à des niveaux
différents dans la région ile de france
on a efo également qui appelle comme
dans beaucoup d'autres départements
la cfe cgc aussi également
critiques dont il n'y a pas non plus il
ya quand même un mouvement qui est assez
large de contestation des projets
actuels oui mais pas non plus d'appels à
la mobilisation avec la cgt demain il ya
quand même cinq ou six organisations en
ile de france qui appelle c'est pas rien
et on va continuer à construire parce
que dans les entreprises de nombreux
militants locaux d'autres organisations
partagent nos critiques et notre besoin
de mobiliser alors vous l'avez évoqué un
petit peu juste avant comment ça va
s'organiser pour les yvelinois pour la
cgt des yvelines des départs de deux
cars vers paris demain on a un oeuf
unions locales dans les yvelines et la
plupart organise donc des cars qui qui
vont se rendre à la à la manifestation
ce qui permet aussi d'échanger des
nouvelles il ya des départs prévus en
train il ya des cars organisée par des
syndicats d'entreprise comme comme à edf
gdf donc vraiment une mobilisation qui
qui fait suite aussi à beaucoup d'heures
d'information d'âgés avec les salariés
dans les entreprises et ça c'est
important qu'on associe le plus grand
nombre de travailleurs à cette
mobilisation
justement parlez d'information ce soir
la cgt 78 animent un débat décryptage
sur les ordonnances de la loi travail
c'est à partir de 18h30 dans vos locaux
de trades telle est l'idée d'ailleurs
c'est de faire aussi de la pédagogie sur
sur ces ordonnances et d aller faire
comprendre aux militants et même aux
autres yvelinois oui parce qu'il ya des
conséquences très concrètes et
contrairement à ce qu'annonce le
gouvernement c'est pas du tout eu dans
le renforcement de la protection des des
salariés bien sûr que le code du travail
actuel nous satisfait pas on a des
propositions pour un code du travail du
21e siècle pour améliorer les droits des
salariés notamment face à la précarité
mais là ça va donner vraiment une
latitudes extrêmes à l'employeur dans
l'entreprise
que ce soit au travers d'accords
d'entreprises qui vont pouvoir déroger
aux conventions collectives au code du
travail
on pourra modifier le contrat de travail
d'un salarié sans son accord et s'ils
refusent il est licencié sec
donc il ya vraiment des choses qui
peuvent avoir des impacts très concret
les conventions collectives elles
permettent un socle commun à l'ensemble
des salariés d'une
branches d'un même secteur c'est
important pour éviter la concurrence par
le bas vous étiez aussi derrière ces
annonces il a peut-être un peu de choses
compliquées il faut donner aussi les
clés pour bien comprendre ces
ordonnances
bah c'est sûr quand on quand on lit des
fois juste les grands titres c'est pas
toujours simple de comprendre les
applications concrètes dont c'est ce
qu'on souhaite montrer voilà comment ça
peut toucher comment certaines primes
présente dans les conventions
collectives par exemple vont pouvoir
beaucoup plus facilement être supprimés
par les employeurs comment les
institutions représentatives du
personnel vont être fragilisés éloigné
des salariés alors qu'il ya un vrai
besoin de proximité notamment sur les
conditions de travail
c'est tout ça qu'on souhaite vraiment
détaillé et du coup donc cette cette
rencontre de ce soir à trappes c'est
auprès de vos militants auprès de toutes
les personnes qui peuvent qui veulent y
assister
ça s'est organisée très vite donc on est
surtout à diffuser l'information à nos
militants elle organise également avec
la fsu 60,18 parce que même dans la
fonction publique il ya de fortes
inquiétudes et des mobilisations puisque
les collectivités locales l'éducation
sont quand même étrangler les hôpitaux
sont dans un état déplorable avec des
personnels vraiment qui travaillent dans
des conditions difficiles
donc tous ces secteurs là aussi ont des
choses à exprimer
est ce qui se fait aujourd'hui pour le
privé rien ne dit qu'on va pas le
transposer dans le public après merci
sonia porot savait que nous je le
rappelle secrétaire départemental de la
cgt 78 la cgt qui appelle demain une
mobilisation nationale contre la réforme
du code du travail et pour être complet
sur ce sujet la grève va impacter
également le trafic des transports en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines dès
ce soir d'ailleurs et pour la journée de
demain
deux trains sur trois circuleront sur le
rer c ce sont trois trains sur quatre
pour la ligne n sur l'ensemble du réseau
en revanche la circulation devrait
devrait être quasi normal pour la ligne
e u
une mobilisation qui pourrait concerner
également les écoles et les comme les
communes doivent s'organiser dans un
communiqué la ville de bois d'arcy
s'engage notamment à faire le maximum
pour assurer les services périscolaires
et la restauration
elle ne connaît pas pour le moment
l'amplitude de ce mouvement est
d'ailleurs à la vesle à la veille de
cette mobilisation nationale contre la
réforme du code du travail indivis mois
s'est exprimé sur le sujet benoît hamon
était l'invité de rmc ce matin l'ancien
député de la 11e circonscription
regrette que les ordonnances n'offrent
pas de réponse aux mutations en cours et
à venir du travail
pour lui cela va créer le plus de
pauvreté et de précarité que d'emplois
pérennes et épanouissant l ex élu
trappistes a également parlé de son
mouvement lancé récemment le m 17 17 qui
contribuera selon ses mots au
rassemblement de la gauche sociale et
écologique et début juillet le
gouvernement a rejeté la demande de
fusion des départements des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines
un projet porté par les présidents de
ces deux collectivités patrick devedjian
et pierre bédier pour évoquer ce sujet
nicolas landry et sur le plateau bonsoir
bonsoir grégory le dossier se retrouve
t'il vraiment au point mort avec cette
décision gouvernementale alors grégory
dans les faits non le gouvernement a
effectivement refusé de créer par décret
un nouveau département issus de l'union
entre le 92 et le 78 un acte
administratif est essentielle pour
permettre l'aboutissement de ce projet
mais pierre bédier et patrick devedjian
peuvent néanmoins poursuivre les actions
déjà engagées
alors c'est un long processus à cette
fusion uvn hauts-de-seine pouvez vous
revenir sur les prémices de ce projet or
rappelez vous de ces images nous sommes
en janvier 2016 lors des voeux de la
nouvelle année une cérémonie commune
présidé par patrick devedjian et père et
pierre bédier pour annoncer la création
au mois de mars d'un établissement
public de coopération
interdépartementale une structure
dirigée par un conseil d'administration
composé par l'ensemble des 88
conseillers départementaux
la première pierre du projet de fusion
entre les hauts-de-seine et les yvelines
et quels ont été les premières décisions
prises sur 7 pour cette structure
premier choix la mutualisation des
services comme l'entretien et
l'exploitation du réseau routier
départemental
le service adoption et l'archéologie
préventive
autre mesure la création d'un aménageur
public commun appelé site adios pour
conclure des marchés publics
ensemble ou
or l'installation d'un conseil
interdépartementale du développement
durable le conseil d'administration a
aussi voté deux budgets
cinq cent mille euros en 2016 et 14
millions en 2010 cet objectif de toutes
ces mesures vous comprenez peut-être
réaliser des économies et permettre de
mener des politiques en commun alors ce
projet rencontre des oppositions et pas
seulement en provenance du gouvernement
effectivement en première ligne on
retrouve les députés de la république en
marge des yvelines je vous propose
d'écouter bruno myle yens le député de
la 9e circonscription mes petits
camarades de la république en marche son
livre à une étude pour voir si ça avait
un sens ou pas quelles étaient les quel
était le département des deux
départements celui qu'en mer on tirait
les plus gros bénéfices visiblement ce
n'est pas forcément les yvelines et
notamment les territoires où j'ai le
document il à la disposition des deux
présidents s'ils veulent le recevoir
ça serait plutôt des avantages des
territoires ruraux des yvelines alors il
y a une autre source d'opposition au
sein même de la majorité départementale
yvelinoise avec les conseillers
départementaux comme yves en val qui
vous le voyez ça lui sur sa page twitter
la décision du gouvernement comme son
collègue philippe brillault en fait tous
les deux sont opposés depuis le début du
projet à cette fusion mais ça n'enlève a
rien là la persévérance du président du
département des hauts-de-seine qui se
dit prêt à avoir à recourir par des
moyens judiciaires à quelques jours
seulement après l annonce du
gouvernement
merci nicolas et pour conclure sur ce
dossier pierre bédier devrait évoquer le
sujet mercredi lors d'un déjeuner presse
après cette longue page politique le
contrôle aérien compte un nouveau venu
un radar d'aviation civile est désormais
installé à palaiseau sur le plateau de
saclay coût du chantier 8 millions
d'euros le projet permettra de guider
les avions jusqu aux aéroports
franciliens
camille lambert
rien ne lui échappe à 300 kilomètres à
la ronde ce nouveau radar inauguré le 8
septembre à palaiseau servira à guider
les avions civils en région parisienne
une structure indispensable qui couvre
la moitié du territoire français ça va
au niveau des vosges ça va au niveau de
bresse pratiquement au sud c'est ça va
du côté de limoges pratiquement donc au
nord ça dépasse largement la france ce
radar voit les avions l'ensemble des
avions qui a dans le ciel et diffuse les
images de ses avions sur des écrans qui
sont situés devant les contrôleurs et
donc les contrôleurs peuvent guider les
avions sur des routes aériennes du haut
d'une tour de 66 mètres de haut il
permettra de guider les avions jusqu aux
aéroports d'orly et roissy charles de
gaulle au-delà de l'aspect pratique ce
projet symbolise aussi le rapprochement
entre les yvelines et l'essonne
ça rentre dans cette logique du
développement du cluster paris saclay
qui est evelyne et sonne donc le cluster
se développe sur trois grands sites jir
le sud du plateau de saclay là dans
l'est dans l'essonne sur palaiseau orsay
et gif mais aussi sur billancourt
puisque c'est très fortement lié aux
activités économiques de recherche qui
assure sur les yvelines et aussi à
satory un développement qui n'est pas du
goût de tous quelques manifestants se
sont rassemblés pour protester contre
l'urbanisation du plateau de saclay la
construction du radar a coûté 8 millions
d'euros 800 avions pourront être
traitées simultanément un souvenir de
l'enfance maintenant plus de 21 millions
d'albums vendus des aventures traduites
dans 25 pays est toujours à l'école
primaire avec sa mèche jaune et son
célèbre tchô titeuf revient dans un
nouvel album son créateur zep était à
rambouillet pour échanger avec le public
mélanie peau qu'elle a rencontrés
vous à deux ans que que l'album
précédent était sortie qui était une
histoire complète cette fois c'est de
nouveau un retour aux fondamentaux
titoff c'est un album de gags et donc ça
permet de traiter plus de sujets quand
c'est une histoire complètement on
développe une idée sur une longue
histoire là c'est dit off qui papillonne
face à ce que je préfère faire avec ce
personnage saute d'un sujet à un autre
il a gommé déjà numéro un des ventes
chez nous ouais c'est chic
le succès s'arrête ne se dément jamais
bah pour le moment pas donc c'est génial
je croise les doigts
il ya des planches sensibles notamment
la première sur le regard des autres les
planches plus dur mais toujours un
regard décalé sur l'actualité en outre
les migrants l'état d'urgence la
pédophilie en fait vous suivez
l'actualité tous les jours bon c'est de
l'actualité qui est qui est large qui a
baigné un petit peu cette année mais
c'est le cas depuis le début au fait
dans titeuf
moi j'avais envie de faire une bande
dessinée contemporaine
ces bandes dessinées qui parle du du
monde dans lequel on vit et puis appuie
aussi enfin j'avais envie que ce soit
réaliste même si je peux mon dessin
n'est pas réaliste mais j'avais envie de
que ce soit en dessinant à laquelle on
retrouve les sujets contemporains parce
que je trouve que quand on est enfant on
ajoute cette idée que les enfants vivent
pas dans le même monde que les adultes
et donc ils sont
on peut qu'on peut leur alors caché une
partie d'arrêter ce qui est pas vrai les
enfants ils entendent tout ils voient
les poils des infos ils entendent et
même si on arrive à les allées préserver
d'une partie de la réalité et leurs
copains vont se charger le débrief est à
l'école et de redire tout ce qu'ils ont
raté donc ils ont besoin de parler tout
ça et titoff il est là dedans donc pour
moi c'est un mélange de enfin c'est ce
qui fait le quotidien mais il n'y a pas
des sujets importants et pas des grands
sujets les petits sujets vu de l'âge de
titoff
tout est sujet de curiosité mais il
n'est pas plus inquiète du plan
vigipirate que de l'interro qui doit
préparer en géographie ça fait partie de
son quotidien
un titre justement il a 25 ans cette
année
il faut le voir dans l'album elle je
peux pas vous le résumé en une phrase
mais 10 portant regards curieux jeu ce
qui est intéressant en fait c qui
comprend pas et qui tente de comprendre
c'est peut-être ce qui le différencie
des adultes on comprend pas mais on fait
comme si on avait compris le sport ce
week-end on jouait le troisième tour de
la coupe de france de football dont les
yvelines
magny les hameaux club de 4e division de
district recevait le blanc mesnil en
nationale 3 soit huit divisions d'écart
malgré une belle résistance les manies
quoi se sont inclinés 6 buts à 2 retour
sur la rencontre avec michael et demi
d'euros les images sont signées nicolas
landry clap de fin pour magny les
hameaux en coupe de france le petit
poucet blinois qui évolue en noir ce
dimanche s'est incliné six ados
troisième tour de la compétition contre
le blanc mesnil
l'équipe qui évolue huit divisions
dessus des manifs quoi tactiquement ils
étaient là au dessus au niveau du
quadrillage du terrain et touba c'était
très compliqué de les contenir et avec
des appels de partout est vraiment un
niveau d'écart ça se ressent on savait à
l'avancé que ce serait difficile après
la logique
elle fait que à chaque fois ils ont été
réalistes devant le but et
notre côté on a fait ce qu'on a pu en a
pris plaisir surtout lémanique ont même
fait mieux que de prendre du plaisir sur
le terrain malgré l'élimination les
joueurs ont réussi à faire douter leurs
adversaires pendant la seconde période
en inscrivant deux buts sur coups de
pied arrêtés et en enchaînant plusieurs
séquences de conservation du ballon
dans notre ve schéma de jeu dans notre
construction de jeu dans la conservation
du ballon il pensait qu'on allait
balancer devant alors qu'on a et j'ai
essayé de construire et dans notre phase
défensive je pense qu'on les a pas moins
de gêne aussi c'est une très très loin
de certaines marques et surtout que
aulas il voulait pas encaissé de but et
ils en ont encaissé dès aujourd'hui nous
ça nous fait du bien au moral pour le
reste de la saison et voilà après cette
parenthèse coupe de france lémanique où
elles devront se mettre rapidement dans
le quotidien du championnat
ils affronteront dès ce dimanche 17
septembre le club de l'ueh civils lors
de la première journée 2 des 4 objectif
monter à la fin de la saison des fêtes
de magny les hameaux donc les autres
club yvelinois n'ont pas été à la fête
non plus quatre clubs 50 saint quentin
en yvelines ont été éliminés ce dimanche
trap a perdu à domicile contre colombes
tout comme montigny le bretonneux défait
par le met sur le même score 4 busin
voisins le bretonneux s'est incliné à
villetaneuse
côté victoires plaisir à dominer la
colombienne et versailles l'a emporté
sur la pelouse de noisy le grand le
championnat interrégional de padel se
déroulait ce dimanche 10 septembre au
paddle club de bois d'arcy
une vingtaine de participants
originaires de plusieurs régions de
l'est de l'ouest de la france étaient
présents objectif la qualification au
championnat de france et découverte de
cette compétition avec nicolas landry
50% le tennis 50% de squash vous obtenez
le padel un sport de raquette opposant
deux équipes de deux joueurs
le but du jeu déstabiliser l'adversaire
dans les échanges pour marquer des
points
la particularité c'est qu'on va avoir la
possibilité en fait de remettre la balle
dans le court adverse
en ces temps durs cette activité attire
beaucoup de joueurs de tennis le cadet
l'eau des marais du club a délaré nador
on pourrait le tournoi s'arrête en demi
ces deux tenniswomen poursuivre leurs
adaptations techniques du padel c'était
justement
et
et voilà s'amuser avec les vitres le
grillage avec ses anciens tennismen les
frères maigri et représente le pet et
les clubs de bois d'arcy à
l'échauffement et préparent leur demi
finale la victoire d'un accès aux
championnats de france ils peuvent
compter sur leur complicité
voilà en tant que moi grand frère ça me
fait toujours plaisir de partager des
moments des bons moments comme des moins
bons de temps en temps aussi suivant les
résultats voilà dans un sport avec lui
on sait quand il faut s'encourager on
sait quand il faut
il faut essayer de motiver l'autre on
sait quel type de balle il va jouer
donc c'est automatique on apprend la pas
travailler qualifié en finale julien et
adrien ont ensuite remporté le tournoi
ils sont assurés de participer aux
championnats de france prévus à
valenciennes les 22 23 et 24 septembre
et puis il n'y avait pas que du sport ce
week-end mais aussi un rendez vous
habituel du début du mois de septembre
lé forum des associations se déroulait
principalement ce samedi et dimanche
c'était le cas pour les douze communes
de saint quentin en yvelines bons
voisins le bretonneux que vous voyez en
images le but rencontrer les bénévoles
de sa commune ou encore s'inscrire pour
une activité culturelle et sportive à
plaisir pour la première fois deux
événements distincts étaient rassemblés
le forum des associations et la fête des
sports au total 110 stands étaient sur
place pour plus de 3000 visiteurs un
succès que la ville a décidé de
reconduire pour les prochaines années
on est ravi parce que il ya eu un vent
de
très important sur l'ensemble de la
manifestation que ce soit à l'extérieur
à l'intérieur dans le palais des sports
mais aussi au niveau du village
on avait installé des food truck pour
pouvoir manger aussi pendant cette
manifestation
donc on est très content vraiment très
content de cette et on a fait une petite
enquête rapide auprès des habitants mais
aussi auprès des associations ayant
aussi rendu compte que il fallait garder
cette méthode on gardera sa pour l'année
prochaine c'est la fin de ce journal
tous nos reportages sont à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]